hello everyone on today's show its
Robert Downey jr. versus Josh Brolin one
plays Ironman one is famous for talking
about their entire careers these two
esteem factors gonna be a lot of movies
gets good it's gonna be still a short
bit give me a fat beat to beat my brush
here's how it works
round number one is box office round
number two that's tomato meter and round
number three is their most iconic roles
and will have a wild card round just to
shake things up and let my personality
shine round number one box office before
we get to mr. jr. let's show some love
to Josh Brolin
he's now firmly entrenched in the MCU
and we pray he never hears another
catchy song again get it cuz like the
finger but Brolin was already in the
throes of a Hall of Fame career before
all this MCU stuff to date he's made 42
movies 36 of which we had box-office
info for and they have gross - combined
2.9 billion dollars at the box office
his per flick average is an impressive
86 million dollars that's a modest hit
in today's economy kids recently his
lifetime stats have been padded by
movies like Deadpool 2 and Avengers
infinity war and now it's here should I
say and speaking of the MCU Robert
Downey jr. is the reason we have one in
the first place sure there's gobs of
hero in every movie now but it all
started with that dirtbag playboy
utilizing his ingenuity in and
Afghanistan cave before emerging as a
reborn superhero the quick wit the charm
the nutty facial hair propelled the
first Iron Man into an international
juggernaut and kicked us off on this
adventure we're still enjoying over a
decade later I'm the best
Robert has done 63 movies total 49 that
we have box-office info for that
includes hits like Sherlock Holmes and
Tropic Thunder all of his efforts
combined have grossed 6.6 billion
dollars that makes for a perfume average
of you want to do the math you something
up I got you
it's a hundred and twenty-two million
dollars per Robert Downey jr. wins the
round easily and gets a hearty thank you
from all of us MCU fans man I'm hit -
told you round - tomato meter this one
is gonna be tougher for Charlie Stark to
win you see what I did there I combined
Charlie Chaplin and Tony Stark anyway I
mentioned Chaplin because it got Robert
his first Academy Award nomination and
fun fact it was directed by dr. John
Hammond from Jurassic Park
for reals I digress Roberts average
movie according to the tomato meter
earns fifty seven point eight percent
and that's aided by hits like shortcuts
which is his highest rated film of 95
percent zodiac and good night and good
luck
well good luck indeed to Josh Brolin and
matching that feat but he almost does
bro ins average filmin tomato meter is
fifty five point six percent and his
overall highest tops
Downey's that would be true grit at 96%
Josh also has celebrated flicks like No
Country for Old Men and milk high on the
list he was nominated for an Academy
Award for Best Supporting Actor for milk
but he lost out the Heath Ledger's
legendary turn as the Joker you know who
else lost out to Heath Ledger that year
Robert Downey jr. for Tropic Thunder hey
look at that we brought it all back
around all told Robert Downey jr. has
been in one Best Picture nominee that's
good night and good luck
meanwhile Brolin has been in a Best
Picture winner No Country for Old Men
as well as two runner uppers milk and
True Grit so I take on this its quotes
but Robert Downey jr. he's been doing it
for longer and so I give him the edge
why are you turning on me like this and
all of a sudden he's got a two-round
lead on the mighty Thanos it was like an
8% chance
eight eight yeah cool
round number three most iconic
characters so you think this would be
another category cakewalk for Robert
because he's Iron Man he even says it
himself
I am
see let's I'm telling the truth on this
show but that's been the bulk of his
fame for the past decade although I do
give some love to Sherlock Holmes but
we've seen so many Sherlock's over the
years
Benedict Cumberbatch Ian McKellen
Christopher Lee Jeremy Brett Will
Ferrell kind of what have we not seen
that much over the years
a truly menacing villain in the MCU
thanks for playing Loki I remember you
Malekith but we've never had anything
like they knows he was lurking behind
the curtain forever he got the power
glove from Nintendo and he did not
disappoint with one snap of those man
handed fingers he wiped out half the
population of the universe them
Guardians they guard the galaxy this guy
took care of the entire universe plus he
got rave reviews for his performances
cable bringing a futuristic emotional
Center to Deadpool 2 all the while
managing to have some laughs and hanging
in with Ryan Reynolds's zingers thirty
Seconds to javelin butt plugs no we're
getting this you can come at me with
your Downey's Chaplin or Harry and Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang but I'm about to drop a
mic on all that noise josh brolin he was
in Goonies boom the round goes the brand
because Goonies unless they get snapped
away in the thing I don't like that
language wildcard round weapon that's
right the wild card today is what these
two accomplished thespians bring to the
table with their wonderful toys if
Brolin wins he ties it up if Robert
Downey wins it's a convincing
three-to-one victory over his MCU
nemesis okay Josh lay it on me what do
you got not my fingers they would all
cease to exist Infinity Gauntlet yeah
that's a good start right there to put
that thing on and basic movements become
a threat to existence a couple that with
all the cool advanced weaponry showcased
and Deadpool - he's way ahead of Downey
however Robert Downey jr. plays a guy
named Tony Stark
big man in a suit of armor take that off
what are you genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist
and to date there's been 50 count'em 50
versions of the Ironman suit in the MCU
we had cool additions like tank missiles
and hulkbusters and more recently we've
been introduced to Starks nanotechnology
we got cluster cannons foot thrusters
and advanced shields stay in school gang
plus he's making spider-man gear and
that just keeps getting more bells and
whistles with every suit so I look at it
this way Tony Stark cannot compete with
Infinity Gauntlet
no one can maybe Bo Jackson however
Thanos didn't make that thing he stole
it he collected the stones and he took
full advantage but Tony the tech genius
made all his stuff himself with an
assist from his old man and like a
bajillion dollars so I like to do it
yourselfers over bullies so I'm gonna
take Robert here and if he need more
evidence he can fly cool planes in Air
America or Sherlock Holmes Sherlock
Holmes has a weapon you know what it is
it's his mind get it it's how science
men's art form this one is a landslide
victory for the actor who was an SNL
cast member back in the day that's my
pick Robert Downey jr. yeah big deal
well it's been a pleasure doing business
with both these fellows there are media
tick advised for me regardless of what
kind of flick they're in they're
engaging they're charismatic did I
mention hey if I didn't they're very
handsome and have you seen Josh Brolin
make a pie my crust is a very forgiving
thing watch Labor Day it's worth the 90
minutes to see that
I'm getting off track here so I
appreciate the memories both these
gentlemen have given me and you and I'm
looking forward to the future that
future is gonna start you the home
viewer because now it's your turn
bow in the comment section right now let
us know who you think should win this
little bout is it Bob or is it Joshy
Ken's do you want to cite detailed
reasons great if you're just wanting to
type a name then that's cool I'm into
the whole brevity thing we'll have
results on a future episode until then
I'm Mark Ellis and I can also snap my
fingers watch me go couldn't do this in
school but I can now